you'd notice a common trend with
everybody that becomes mega-wealthy with
them and their biggest struggles with
their family students you've got a child
especially a boy at that point where he
can look his mother in the eye it
becomes a power struggle my parents were
divorced they didn't have a lot of money
you know was it my dad my mom thought I
was a drug dealer my mom thought I was
like so many of these kids I've only
ever been analyzed from one perspective
I know children to me like children of
the mega wealthy family yeah
they they're absolutely ruthless you're
failing in school and you're failing in
just in life in general nothing seems to
make any sense
building a young family what can they
start doing now to prevent getting to
the point of what you're saying today
and wasn't saying why you're broken is
saying where are you strong
[Music]
you know one of the things I believe in
is if you want to learn about me you can
get so much information about me by
asking me questions but the best way to
learn about me is by asking folks that
work with me on a daily basis so anybody
you want to learn about ask the people
that know them best
today's guest is Mark demos who wrote a
book called the DNA code he's also the
co-founder of talent DNA and one of the
things he specializes in is dealing with
families that are mega-wealthy above a
hundred million and these are
billionaires folks above 100 million and
they come together with them any kind of
family challenges that they may have
they go through working with them and
that's what he specializes in seven said
that mark thank you for being against my
team I really appreciate it
so when did you wake up and says you
know I want to be around these guys that
are mega wealthy and help them with
their family legacy like how did that
come about you know I was brought up in
a lot of wealth
growing up went to a really great school
looked like a castle looked like Harry
Potter
so grew up around a lot of wealthy
people and then also when I came to the
US and I landed up in Redmond Washington
I was raising my children there going to
Redmond high school is where Microsoft
is so I used to wonder is this by the
way when I got to Redmond in about 91 92
K and so really got to know all of the
parents a lot of the parents have come
to me with their problems and one
weekend one of the parents said well do
you have a program that yeah we get the
have SOG we don't have to send our kid
to overseas so I said yeah we do so I
put it together over that weekend and by
Tuesday morning we had everything up and
running and end up actually having my
kids work with me with a lot of these
kids who were younger than probably two
three years younger but that's when I
started and and what did you see from
because you know a lot of people out
there you know I want to be a
millionaire now I wish I was a Mega
Million I wish I was all this have you
noticed a common trend with everybody
that becomes mega-wealthy with them
and their biggest struggles with their
family I have you know it's not with all
of them but I I've seen the big issue
with all of them is this how do i define
my life personally how do i figure out
what matters in life when i don't have
to do anything and i will be okay i
don't have to find out what I'm good at
I know children you mean like children
either mega-wealthy family yeah and even
put into the parents you know with a lot
of the early Microsoft families they got
wealthy very quickly and I remember you
an article back in the mid 90s about all
these young bachelors who now were three
for five million dollars and they didn't
know who was their friend why did they
why did someone want to date them when
nobody would go near them in college and
so now they had money and all of a
sudden they were there were somewhat
celebrities so I was trying to figure
out why does someone love me why does
someone want to be in my universe and be
around me so it really becomes a
question that involves all of my life
and friendship and relationship is one
of the huge issues with people with
money how do you know they want to be
with you how do you know they're your
friends Wow what a good point so just
not knowing who who's a real friend and
was there just for the money part that's
right and you know you ask most people
who doesn't want to be friends with
someone who's really wealthy because you
get to go to nice places you get to see
nice things you meet famous people and
everyone wants to be around him and they
don't know who's who
it's a real struggle Wow so so there
their challenge is one those who are
worth a hundred million and up the kids
challenge is a different story right
give us some examples of what you've
seen on both sides I think for the kids
the big issue becomes why do I have to
do anything for a lot of these kids as
well when they do something wrong the
parents can hire an attorney I remember
working with a kid at Redmond High
School and they've broken into the
school Talia broke into the chemistry
lab and was in juvenile courts so
juvenile court you do something like
that and you're gonna get a slap on the
wrist the parents put together a team
like the OJ Simpson trial they they had
three or four experts at 3:40 Germany's
army and then they found out when you go
to juvenile court you really can't use
yeah you really can't do that it's a
judge you don't have a jury
and it just becomes something it's a
false sense of really never having to
thrive in life to create your own
happiness because there's a trust fund
there's money down the road I will
always be okay and the problem with
human beings is this what I don't know
what I've got to give to this world and
I'm dependent on what my parents made or
my grandparents made or their name and I
don't find out who I am and what I've
got to give it's not just of lack of
purpose there's depression there's
anxiety there's just almost a
self-hatred because I'm useless in this
world I know what I've got to give so
how do i how do you help them get there
how do you help them get clarity very
often it's trying to help the parents
it's helping the parents push these kids
to engage in life it's not lying these
parents to bail their kids out it's not
very often having these kids you know
these parents send their kids to schools
where their name is known and their yeah
they they've donated the football field
there's a big building on campus I had a
friend that I went to college with his
name was Mark Tomas identical name when
I first landed in college I thought I
was a celebrity I didn't know who this
guy was but I was treated for about
three days like I was an absolute brick
until three days later I walk in campus
I'm a foreign student I don't know
anyone and I see this author Tomas
building and his dad had found a pen
life insurance and but it was really
interesting the dad died young but these
kids the three kids didn't inherit
anything till they graduated from
college they were married they had
children and that they had worked for
themselves for at least a few years I
don't know what what the that was his
system how he created it that that was
the way he did it make your own way in
the world and it's very difficult
because parents always want their kids
to have a better life than them but you
can't give your kids a better life when
you've taken your challenge you've
applied it and then think that you can
have a kid well not do anything in life
and create their own identity they trade
off yours and you can't do that with
anything in life so so is it is it do
you ever sit anywhere say okay these
kids can be saved because there are five
six ten years old they can be safe
but these kids cannot be saved because
they're 25 years old they're already on
drugs their party and have access to
anything and everything cocaine you know
ecstasy xanax vicodin whatever they want
I don't know how I'm gonna say these
guys is it different on how you deal
with these parents and their kids at
different stages of how their kids are
generally the parents will call us today
the kids are teenagers and they're ready
acting out so for most parents they they
they probably do a good job early on or
they think they're doing a good job but
it still becomes a problem when again
you named after grandpa and you're named
after ya your father and you number
three or number four and everybody knows
who you are and everybody treats you
differently so it really is running
engaged with parents early on if parents
are willing to engage to give their kids
as normal in a life as possible and so
often it's it's a real struggle because
parents want to give their kids more
they want to give their kids opportunity
but kids have to learn how to earn it
and so what we do with a lot of these
kids is we make them go get a jump if
they're 16 and they can work and they
stay they have the ability we get them
to go out and work and know what a
paycheck means we get them to find
places to give money that they've earned
not to give away what their parents have
earned what if they rebel against it
what if they luck I don't want to have
my job I'm not gonna keep it and you
can't force it to keep it now we can't
and they ultimately become so well the
parents buy into what we're trying to
say because it's a very small window of
opportunity
very seldom can you work with a kid once
they're over 18 or 19 and they're out
there ready and everything you know
everything is already taken care of
they're in university and for a lot of
male drop out of university they will be
on drugs they will be they will have not
run away they'll just have disappeared
they've got a credit card and they can
use it whenever they want so for some of
the parents that's saying you've got to
cut them off you have got to allow them
to be able to create their own life but
the greatest worry that every parent has
is but he'll hurt himself or herself
they'll kill themselves and they've
already got their enough examples out
there of young of children who have
common is that from parents fears is
that very
, for you when you see that I think it's
more common with with children of wealth
of wealthy people because they've tried
everything and they haven't found
anything that really delivers back to
them something a real substance in life
they don't have a sense of purpose and
they've relied on and they've tried
every drug they've tried every vacation
they've gone everywhere they've met
people
nothing has been denied them and I it's
my own personal belief that nothing
external is ever gonna touch my life
until I figure out what my life has that
I can give to impact the life of another
person it's empty until I do if I give
away my parents money what have I done
nothing I haven't earned it I haven't
used a sweat of my brow to go and work
and to give to somebody something that's
gonna cost me it doesn't cost me
anything if I give away my parents money
so you hear a story like Jay Paul Gettys
you know you and I were talking about
Jay paul Getty you know wonder richest
billionaires he built some incredible
probe into his Museum in LA and the
criticism he gets when he died what he
did with his money you know everybody
says that this guy was a cheapskate with
his family he was a terrible father he
left nothing for his kids his boys
that's that's the terrible example of a
father what do you say about what he did
I think there's a lot in terms of learn
morality that was problematic inside
sure yes you know growing up better I I
would I would almost err on the side of
saying let your kids figure it out
themselves push them to find out who
they are push them to find out what
they've got to give to life and it's not
giving to life what you've created
yourself they have got to find out
themselves and there are ways to do that
we you know I told a young guy who's
coming to to Dallas tomorrow that did
just that we helped him define his life
separate from everything else in his
family and he's created life he had
dropped out of two universities was
failing out of everything and he's now
engaged in life he's actually going to
come work with us and work with college
students to try and help them figure out
who they are to do what you're doing
what you do what we're doing B now how
wealthy was his family what
what kind of work that is family after
family owns a major league baseball team
they own a major mutual fund combined
family worth still probably around 1012
billion dollars so I mean that's no
limit whatever is not you can get
anything you want and they have and
they've met everyone and they've been
everywhere and they they lack nothing
anything you want you can have how much
did this guy you're talking about get
close to the breaking point very I'm
talking break more like killing himself
we were called out to go to his home
with his mother's home in Vermont to be
able to get him out of his room and he
was locked in there and he's like he's
we've got permission to share his story
because he wants other other young
people to know he was he was strung out
on drugs everything imaginable and he
had just lost hope and everything and
when you you're failing in school and
you're failing in just in life in
general and nothing matters nothing
seems to make any sense and then to come
to him to ask him start saying well what
are you great and what do you accept not
what have you what do you know you can
give to touch the life of another person
with and it wasn't trying to do the
mental health thing he'd seen therapist
psychiatrist he'd seen everyone it
wasn't saying why you're broken it's
saying where are you strong what what's
unique about you that you have when you
understand it you can impact the life of
somebody else
and focusing on that you know one of the
things we did within a year of that we
he went to San Francisco for an
internship we were up in Vermont again
and we said well Charley Winnie what are
you going he said well next week I'm
going so I said well how you gonna get
there well I'll I'll fly in my mom will
ship the car so said Charley you've got
two days you're gonna get your car ready
it was Christmas in Vermont good ice
everywhere and I said you gonna drive
you got to get in your car and you got
to drive he's never seen this country
except from a and he it was one of
the big things in his life that he
simply drove across this country he
didn't even think was possible wasn't
even something that heavy
you tell me gonna roadtrip I'd be I've
tried through Africa through Europe I've
made every state in the US if I got an
opportunity to travel I will and he did
and was the firm one of the first major
things that he began to do where he knew
he could do it without anybody else
doing it for him and he was in his early
20s by then what was his reaction
afterwards you know about like the
conversation was alike he went to stay
with his aunt who's the prison of a
major mutual fund company up until this
point no one would ever hear from
Charlie he was quiet he was this total
introvert anyhow he's going across
country and I mean woken up in the
middle of the night pictures from the
day he's texting me as he's cross
country what is this place really
through Utah you see he's you know he's
sending me pictures of Salt Flats and he
didn't even know they existed and you
know and he gets to San Francisco and we
see his his aunt a few months later in
Nantucket and she says well someone
turned Charlie off he can't shut his
mouth anymore he had nothing to say in
life before that he now had a life to
share and it becomes ya really became
something so different now as Charlie's
the grandson right he's one and how many
grandkids did this family of 12 billion
have there are 16 16 over 16 grand out
of the 16 how many of them did you work
with yourself or two of them yeah and
Howard if percentage-wise you know
because you see how this affects it I've
read a book a few years ago 15 16 years
ago called the ultimate gift it's a
story of a billionaire where he's gonna
give this thing to his nephew were 12
lessons you got to go watch these videos
and he dies and you know the whole
center display yeah so the person dies
you know he has his attorney sitting
here all the people are sitting there
saying you're here to get my Walt here's
what we're gonna do but the chances of
these kids making it is slim to none out
of the 16 how many are living a normal
life were there fulfilled they're happy
they're making a difference in people's
lives I know three of them that are
added a 69 you know I'm not certain
aswhat the I know quite a few of them
are really struggling really really
badly and so I mean I I have met all of
them I've met quite a few of them
but what I what I understand is that
most of them are really struggling to
really become something in life with
every opportunity bar none there was
nothing that they couldn't or were you
know had the ability to do yeah the
grandfather I think gave about 400
million to Yale University so he's he's
really invested in Canadian to you to
Yale University very invested in
education believes in it and opportunity
and wealth and all those things don't
determine the outcome ultimately becomes
down to regardless of what oh hell it's
my life if you willing to look at your
life and say this is who I am and this
is what I have to give it's a very
simple formula you cannot be happy and
you cannot be have friends and you
cannot find purpose in this life till
you know what you've got to give to
impact the lives of others with out of
those 16 can you do anything to the
other 13 that have no desire to change I
met with one of them when Charlie was in
town a few months back went top golf and
kids a scratch golfer and he was on a
scholarship at a the University in
Southern California he's not doing
anything now I tried to reach out to him
he was the first one that we actually
worked with and continues just to
struggle with life didn't get passed
probably one semester of SMU and that
was it and has not really gone back to
school has just drifted it's really sad
because he's a really personable kid
really like him and my hope is well
we'll meet up again when Charlie comes
into town and you know somehow that I
can impact his life but ultimately it
comes down to choice so if I don't want
to do anything I don't want to change
there's nothing you can do to help no
change so step number one is me being
willing to want to do something about it
yes
so you're saying Charlie at the point
where you had to go get him from his
room and pull him out he said mark
police help me now I want to do
something absolutely okay so step number
one as a person wanting to change okay
so from Urich is there a point of no
return is there like you know in in you
said you could pitch 90 miles an hour
crooked
because you can jump high you can do a
lot of things but you can't run very
fast right true true so but but you know
there's certain people that you look at
and you say okay this guy can be saved
and pitching they'll say past this age
is too late you know if you wave above
this as a person that wants to go be a
jockey for Kentucky Derby just now you
and I can never be jockeys no sources
sure wouldn't be able to race anything
about you
our bodies are not made for Jah true but
is there a point of no return to say
these kids can no longer be saved is it
15 is a 20 25 30 or is it age doesn't
matter it's the person says I'm sensible
I think it really does interesting I I
think office 16 17 18 it becomes very
difficult and the older becomes more
difficult but again I get my my personal
belief is moral choice and spiritual
choice whatever you want to call it is
available throughout our lives I think I
look at some people I think they can
never come back from this they're done
they they're just so hard or they just
don't nothin medicine whatsoever and I
admit a few and very interesting but I I
just I can never believe moral choice is
taken away from people and the ability
to own their own lies and to say how do
I give to people honestly and openly so
so then I'll take a step back I read a
book many years ago called 101 questions
to us before we get engaged I am all
about anticipation I think if the people
I had a meeting today three-hour meeting
with one of our executives very
difficult meeting today they came in he
and his wife and I spent three hours
talking about anticipation anticipated
XYZ say I'm watching this say I'm
listening to this and I listen to what
you're saying I'm saying this is amazing
and I just shared this with my brother
my brother's worth 120 million he just
sold the stocks he just got married
they're about to have kids or they have
kids what are some things I 120 million
dollar person or the six hundred million
dollar person that's building a young
family what can they start doing now
to prevent getting to the point of what
you're saying today it's the same with
all the parenting I really believe it
and that is you you study your children
you watch them they're all unique
they're all different I have three kids
they are all so different
it's looking at and it's beginning to
say what matters to my children well you
know what with one you can have a kid
hurt in the playground and one runs up
and he's putting his arm around him and
another one's running for help it's just
they they react differently of things so
it's really watching your kids it's
saying what are they loving terms of
school you know is that what subjects to
they love in school who are their
friends what sort of people do they
befriend
watch their emotions I watched my oldest
son he's as steady as could be he is you
know he he takes things in stride
my other son Adam can handle crisis it
doesn't matter what crisis comes at him
he will handle it Andre you don't want
to again I have major crises coming into
his life it's not spontaneous at all but
he just handles life very slow very
pedantically
and he handles it very well everything
is planned out and everything is well
measured and so I think you really as
with everything in life you study you
watch you observe you ask them why you
know why did you do that why does it
matter why why are these friends people
you want to be around what is it you've
given to your friendships today what is
it you did at school that made you come
alive something that I I really got onto
a few years ago as a concept called flow
and if you know much about folk in
sports they call it being in the zone in
spirituality you know they there's a
movie called Chariots of Fire where he
talks about the pleasure of God and flow
is when you find out what is exceptional
about someone you you find that high
talent in the flairies of life and you
find places to engage it you treat each
child differently but when you see that
they have something exceptional yeah you
create opportunity for that specifically
not just in general yo can you elaborate
on that when you find out as some things
where you create opportunities for that
specific thing what do you mean by that
so you you might have a kid who's really
good at sport but you know you were a
football player but this kid is the
football player maybe he's a is a
baseball player
you don't try and create him in your own
image feed feed the stream feed what
direction that's going and feed the
things that your children love flow
getting back to that is when you see a
kid anxious very often a child is being
pushed to do something they don't have a
unique capacity to do so I think even in
terms of college students when you watch
the anxiety that is so prevalent in
university campuses so many of them are
trying to be something that they not
they read only another capacity a lot of
them cheat all of them plagiarize to go
the software try to catch kids
plagiarizing and lying and anxiety is
just that it's trying to be something
you're not you don't have the innate
national talent flow is when you have
their talent and you've given the
opportunity you watch when time flies
with a kid that's one of the hallmarks
of flow a kid goes in their room and
they start reading or they they go out
in the garden and they start building a
fort you know and hours go by and the
kid comes in and yeah he said well we
William they said well I just went
outside ten minutes ago they've been out
there three hours when you engage talent
with with a challenge time flies
emotional problems go away
people feel alert they feel alive they
connect with other people so it's
observing and understanding things like
flow and talent engagement well you were
you a year will you at the time hundred
million plus yourself when you were
raising your kids no I was not you know
I had at 100 I've been homeless a number
of times after I got my kids back I came
to this country I was from Zimbabwe
being in from Zimbabwe I ended up as a
man without a country I ended up having
to try and raise my kids not being a lot
of work a lot of the time my children
were abducted I spent three years
running around this planet trying to get
my kids back
I lost almost everything I lost you know
I ended up living in a van with my kids
at times life did get better but it also
was up and down constantly and about
2008 I ended up going trying to get a
work permit and up in federal detention
for a number of months an ankle bracelet
for two years really because I'm a man
without a country I'm here legally I
always keep me I again I came in
he was always here legally but something
got lost in Homeland Security after 9/11
and life became very convoluted and
rather complex for a long time I bet so
but you said you came to the states 79
right to college in 79 79 and then you
were you started you moved to Seattle at
9:00 on window South Africa after that I
was actually a minister for about six
years inside laughs in South Africa it
went through a divorce my wife left
she was from Seattle so went back there
and ended up in a big custody case where
she keep abducted the children two more
times so you moved there because that's
where the kids were at yeah I I'm a
father I love my children of course no
so so so that's the your story is very
interesting all over the place you've
been in this stuff you've done but going
back to the question about somebody
watching us they're worth 120 million
six hundred million the challenge is
like when I was coming up the challenges
I had as a kid my parents were divorced
they didn't have a lot of money you know
wasn't my dad my mom thought I was a
drug dealer my mom thought I was like
you know she was wondering what this guy
was all these other things so people
coming in and out all the time but the
it is different
I would assume if a kid is raised in a
family worth a hundred million plus
right I would assume that's a very big
difference what are those challenges
that parents can see because right now
like in Plano where I known Addison
headquarters are not essential planos
down the street when we were first
moving to Texas when we were looking at
different cities they said Plano had a
massive heroin epidemic back in the 90s
and the 80s and all these kids were
using heroin and everybody here was
talking about true be careful with Plano
and I said how did it even take place
then I started asking then they said
listen you know a private school parents
have access to more money and these kids
get bigger allowances and one kid found
out about heroin and he tested it and he
shared it with other people
next thing you know it lasted 15 20
years okay that's a story of Plano what
are some of the challenges you see with
parents who have that who are just
having a newborn because I know you
asked your question I sure do you think
there's a point where it's too late and
you said yes there is but I've also seen
people change right what are some of
those preventative things a parent of
it's apparent worth a hundred plus
mega-wealthy what can they do now
and I know some of the stuff you said
it's the same as everything else it's a
raising kids all this other stuff
there's got to be something that's
different about a parent that's 100
million versus somebody else what are
some things they can do now so they can
prevent some of these things are from it
from happening I think it's also it's
looking analyzing there definitely some
parents have that hundred million
because they're inherited others have
owned it I think it's really important
to give kids chores early on to have
them be responsible for certain parts of
the environment their rooms cutting the
grass learning how to do simple things
that you don't pay you know you can pay
others to do but you do them as a family
I think it's vitally important that both
parents be on the same page that you
can't go to one and ask for something
and they say no and you go to the other
and you can manipulate them and that is
common to most you know most situations
but teaching young yo young lives to
take to take control of their lives
early if they need a tutor make sure
they need a tutor
don't just hire a tutor because they not
you know they they lazy you got to push
them you make sure that they attempt
something before you bring in outside
help simply getting outside help and
allowing kids not to develop is
problematic thinking you can hire an
expert for everything parents are the
best experts in the child's life
thinking you can hire a psychiatrist
psychologist educational consultant good
parenting present parenting being around
and being present in your child's lives
when you've gotten every opportunity to
travel and be everywhere else and be
working 80 hours a week that that won't
hurt you it'll hurt anyone
being afraid having a father present in
his child near his children's lives I
think is more vital especially in the
teenage years and anything it's not that
mothers become irrelevant but soon as
you've got a child especially a boy who
B is taller than his mother at that
point where he can look his mother in
the eye there becomes a power struggle
right there and that's why I go for me
as a parent you're a big guy I'm a big
guy but it requires a bit of pushing
with your children it requires being
physical with your children
it requires interacting with them in the
middle by physics not hurting them but
playing games of them referencing your
area but la semana boxing with these
boys and just tumbling up a little bit
it is but it's being a bigger physical
presence and they are so many issues we
have with with police now is that you
know teenagers don't respect please they
they're told to stop and no one's ever
stopped them before appearance never
said don't and the parent grabbed them
and said that's enough I had to do with
my my children I mean I come back one
day and I'm looking for my kids that we
just moved to a really nice house and
you know being Microsoft from these
apartments and I couldn't find them and
they'd gone back to the apartments I go
looking for them and I smell them down
in this ravine smoking weed so I said
nothing got them back to the house and I
grabbed my 16 year old at that point and
I picked him up and put him against the
wall and you know my daughter was
screaming her head off my 14 year old
son say leave him alone I didn't hurt
him but I got his attention I got it
very physically to say don't you ever
you know you don't ever put yourself and
you don't put your your family or your
brother in the situation like that again
and you know I it just it requires you
being there it requires you being a
presence and that demonstrates love
thinking you can give your kids things
that are more valuable than you you lose
you will always lose thinking you can
give your kids things that are more
valuable than you you will lose your own
presence and your own your own president
rather than about your car about your
house about you this rather than I'm
giving you my time very interesting yeah
and you were saying when we were talking
you were saying something about Harvard
the kids are struggling right now with
anxiety and panic attacks and they're
having to hire more psychologists to
deal with these students that are
dealing with anxiety and panic do you
see that as an increase are we having
more panic and anxiety attacks today
than before and why is that it is the
major issue on college campuses now the
American Psychological Association like
I hate doing
sixth but about two years ago talked
about 60% of college students will seek
help for anxiety related issues you know
normally within their first year they're
going to seek out a therapist because
they're anxious they worried they've
never looked up enough from their phone
and now they're away from home and
they've got to live with a new roommate
they've got to engage with people on
campus they don't know how to do it
without getting drunk without getting
wasted and somehow the most common the
way in which you form social
relationships is going out and getting
drunk with people or hooking up with
people and then all of a sudden you know
you you've got to deal with it the
aftermath of all of that and it's
problematic one of our board members is
a lady called dr. Monique Rinna and she
was the Dean of Students at Harvard and
she said her primary tasks when she was
there was to set up and to hire new
therapists to be able to deal with what
she called a pool of anxiety and you
think you want to go to Harvard Grace
place on the plan for education and it's
just the cesspool of anxiety everybody
worried everybody acting out doing
things that are crazy and what are they
worried about I mean it's is it is that
the pressures of social media is that
the pressures of who's got the bigger
butt who's gotten more followers who's
getting more likes who's getting better
grades or what is the pressure
everything because once you go to
Harvard pretty much your life's made you
have a network of people that when you
need a job you leave Harvard you've got
to jump you're not going to have to
worry about much because that network as
with most Ivy League schools that's why
parents want them to go that you've got
a network of extreme wealth yeah you got
Harvard with almost 40 billion dollars
in endowment from they don't have to
charge for anything sure they do but
it's just a way to keep you know the
Alumni connected and pouring money in
and getting tech you know area but why
do you think why would someone be
anxious why would wealthy kids be
anxious and it's all the same thing I
think so many of these kids are the Ivy
League's have only ever been factored or
analyzed from one perspective they're
excellent academically they know how to
memorize and they know how to perform
academically but if they don't get the
score on a test that they think they
deserve
they they fall apart they will act out
they will hire attorneys they will four
grades four grades they absoluteness for
grades oh they will hire them and
teachers are petrified you it's it's
very it's almost impossible to get a
Seon in most Ivy League universities now
try and get a seat what get it you'll
get an A or a B and it's almost like
they've been taken off the table because
they don't want the again the
administration doesn't want to have to
deal with the ramifications of some kid
who they admitted and said is proficient
in big to be in Harvard they that means
they not they not able to get a C and
it's really a very false I mean it's
very demanding it's an amazing place to
be but when you're only know your life
based on how you can perform
academically and how your mind can work
and then all of a sudden you're out of
your home environment and with you know
a few thousand other kids who just as
bright as you you're not special anymore
everybody else is special as well they
came from and I find it with athletes as
well got a coded college you were the
best soccer player or football player
you got to go to college everybody else
is the best as well in this in the high
school so is this some of that good
isn't some of that like normal you know
because sometimes like what I look for
is to follow and here's what I look for
I look for you know you know we used to
do this much business now we're doing
this much but the quality used to be you
know very good not equalities bad so I
want to find out wait a minute what
happened here for the quality get right
running a business so how much of this
is today of the anxiety and panic versus
how much of it is I mean 50 years ago I
was a good athlete in high school then I
went to college oh my gosh these guys
are so much better and I go to the NB
a-- or MLB or whatever I'm like there's
so much more pressure to perform or else
I lose my contract or Hollywood you know
women or men show you got a little bit
of a belly Disgaea who's the Aquaman's
guy what's his name doc one actor's name
what is his name you know Jason Momoa
did I say right so this Jason Momoa guy
good-looking guy right I mean people
think this guy is an absolute stud so he
posts a picture the other day I don't
know if you saw this or heard about
he said a picture somebody got a picture
of them and they have a belly Twitter
goes crazy off this guy right look at
this guy he looks like a dad what
happened to this guy used to be a stud
and now he looks like a dad all this
others but is it new or is it just more
you know bigger today because of social
media we see it faster there's more
eyeballs to it so are a lot of these
anxiety and panic attacks that we hear
about today is it truly going higher
because of social media or is it just
hey it's what we're gonna go through our
kids are gonna go through you and I went
through what everybody's gonna go
through it all right I think it's worse
already do I think social media really
fuels it and social media lets us live
in a very on a very shallow basis and
it's a very fast basis it's very shallow
and I think if you don't have the death
to know who you are you will be taken
out if you can't see yourself as bigger
than the criticism because you know yeah
I did forensics for many years and one
of the things that you learn in
forensics when you go to trial is if you
don't have the the evidence and you
can't argue the evidence you've got a
real problem you you you can't just you
can't make a long noise and think that
you're going to get through and somehow
you're not getting it cross-examined but
if you are convinced of the evidence and
you've done the work and you've done the
forensics you've done that eyewitness
test me you've done the forensic testing
that DNA you've got all that you've got
all the facts if you don't have the
fence you've got a shouting screen and
if you don't have the facts you will you
will drop
it's the same with bullying you're not
going to stop bullying on any you know
whether it's a corporate bullying or
academic org in high schools you've got
to make kids stronger because bullies
will always be there and bullies know
how to find the weak and if you don't
have something to come back at a bully
what to say no I am this is what I know
about myself you become the prey of the
bully so you can be academically bullied
you can be physically bullied you know I
did an interview two three years ago the
local station here about bullying and
yeah it Richardson high school we run a
out-of-school suspension program there
and I basically told you know this
mother that I was dealing with in yeah
as part of the interview I said take
your kid on in you know do martial arts
if you want to help your kid not get
bullied on the way back from school you
get your kids stronger physically you
may not be big physically now but teach
him how to protect himself teach him
something that he's gonna learn that he
can he can counteract that not have to
run you know he doesn't run fast enough
to outrun these bullies same
academically finds something that you're
great at socially find a place where you
can demonstrate capacity and demonstrate
how you can impact and touch people's
lives with so when you do that you
always have a place where you shine
you've always got a place where you have
something to give it's important to life
so you're saying bullying is something
that's inevitable and so forget about as
a kid coming up bullying as an adult so
what is a solution to prevent bullying
from happening to you because it's not
gonna go away
I mean bullying happens in business
bullying happens in sales well it
happens with everywhere right no matter
no matter if you were six years old 15
years old 22 years old or 45 years old
that happens how do you handle bullying
as an adult and I'm not saying bullying
as in hey you're driving to work I open
the window and I hit you in the face I'm
talking psychologically yes so show me
you can be bullied all the time but you
know and if you don't know that you have
something exceptional and somebody says
you useless you are fat you are this
year if you don't know what you've got
again it's just somebody it sounds trite
that sounds what do you mean by you
don't know what you got is it like if
you don't know what you have to offer to
the world what what do you mean when you
say when you don't know what you so
someone says oh she's so stupid she does
again I will chick new show boob yeah
I'm you know it gets kind of crass but
it's it's saying no you know what Who I
am is I go volunteer on the weekends I
tutor kids when you're bullied and
things have said about you that are
untrue and you have to try and react to
the untruth is something you can never
win you've got to pull that you've just
got to let it go
you can't defend what isn't you can't
defend what is well you can't how do how
do you defend an accusation and whatever
sessoms but if you don't say anything
and that becomes a truth to most people
because you didn't defend it isn't it
because if you you talk about the
current administration you know the guy
he he doesn't let anybody say anything
about this guy he comes back in attacks
are you saying
of what he's doing and that approach may
not be most effective because a lot of
times I'll have yesterday we did a
meeting with this lady phenomenal lady
we brought her in to kind of take the
culture of home office because we have
sales and we have home office so we
brought her in as a mediator to kind of
see what she can do to bring out the
best so she interviewed everybody
everybody she has 26 questions we've
been dealing we've been going through
with this for a few weeks and yesterday
we sat down we had this conversation and
everybody kind of started saying well
you know we're this and we're that with
this then she went through the deck and
she said here's what these people said
and here's what that participate but no
name so nobody could tell who was
frustrated would know right so then I
paused and I said I want you guys to
know something cure you know the seven
things here I'm gonna stop pause and I'm
gonna address it with everybody because
if I don't this that is someone's truth
but it's not the truth could become the
truth if I don't defend it and here's
what I want to do with the seven do you
guys have any challenge with these seven
so I kind of went through the points
that to make then enough people came in
and we realized who some of the people
that said these statements then it got
clear no that's not the truth here in
the office but you're saying is if
somebody says something if it's not the
truth you're saying don't defend it in
most circumstances I mean really I mean
I many years ago I was accused of
something I never did it took three
years for it to tomorrow had to figure
out and almost 24 all the truth to come
out what I had a focus on is water I
knew that I was a father and I was going
to be present in the lives of my
children it it hurt opportunities for
work and hurt opportunities for jobs and
hurt opportunities for many things
ultimately you've got to choose what you
value in life would you have done
anything differently with that unknown
what accusations happen with you I
couldn't use they're untrue
I mean to be accused of something untrue
you know I had to go to court and I had
to disprove them to the best of my
ability so I think you know I guess I
guess the point is you so here's what I
mean by that Instagram people get on
there and they say what they say okay I
don't have time to go through 700
comments and they tell me whole here's
what happened here's what happened
here's what's going on with this here's
what's going on with that I don't
time for that right I don't have time to
go through all that stuff but if a
person who is a credible person and as a
known person decides to attack and they
start fabricating some words and saying
you know here's what they're doing
creating rumors defamation of character
whatever you wanna call it
aren't those two different things though
I think they are
yeah I've assists at the moment who's
dealing with an issue like that and you
know she's had to seek legal counsel for
that and is gonna be dealing with that
but it's hurt her ability to function as
a professional you know for 30 years no
no issue and then has to have someone
the husband of the person she has the
issue with go to a professional board
and lie about her it got kicked out
after about two years but you know it
these things will hurt but I think
ultimately it's what do you know at the
core of who you are that is strong that
is steady and I think we get so
distracted from really engaging and
impacting the lives of other people
there will always be critics in our
lives
know now let us stop know that there
will be people who will hurt us the more
successful you become there will be
people who will want to hurt you and so
the choice is how much time do you give
to them rather than going and finding
more opportunities to grow and develop
your business and it's grown to develop
your relationship yeah it's the same
with personal relationships with a
husband and wife you know someone may
say something but again I I know with my
wife that I have full trust in her I
didn't for many hits because of what
happened with my first marriage but I
know my wife can trust me I have there's
not a question I was off to Italy in a
few weeks time you know with a number of
woman we have a thing called retreat to
Tuscany and she's gonna be she's gonna
be there for tenure I don't have no fear
of what my wife will do and that she has
no fear of what I will do while she's
away I trust her how different is that
now than it was before
what I accusations or you know an upsell
like what's a difference I know her for
who she is rather than you know I think
so much in terms of relationship we get
attracted to people
we put on a front weep there they see us
for what we project to them and what I
really learnt in the many years I was
not married is that when I look to be in
relationship with someone I want them to
know who I am the best of who I am to
describe my strengths have people that
know me be able to authenticate their
truth that I have a track record that
she can see me in action in different
parts of my life that I can see her that
I know her for who she is not for a pain
not for her failings not for those
things are all common to life we all
have our pain we all have our trauma we
all other things that we fear in life
speaking like a pastor right now I am
using other strengths yeah
no I want you to give to relationship
not what you have to fix on the other
person no I'm fully with that but you
you you you for second I'm like another
church and so let's transition actually
you and I were talking earlier and you
said that Howard Schultz's name came up
right we would come at Howard Schultz
and we're talking about I don't know how
how how did Howard Schultz come up what
were you talking I did work for his
company Mavs run back in the late 90s
madness is a venture capital company yes
you work with his memory I did venture
capital company and then the
conversation went from there to you know
him running for office and I said I
don't think Howard Schultz knows how to
answer tough questions he gets rattled
he gets nervous and you can't do that
maybe some of these guys are better
one-on-one people than they are would he
call it a camera on you people because
there's two different answers
yeah there's a reacts and there's people
I've seen one-on-one that are
unbelievably powerful you put them on
stage they are horrible and then there's
people I've seen that are incredible on
stage you put in one-on-one they're so
nervous with you you can't even hang
with a conversation so obvious the
Howard doesn't build a company or
400,000 employees not being good one on
one that's very obvious yeah you don't
build a company 400,000 employees and go
and do where Starbucks now is everywhere
and then I asked you a question I said
did you have dealings you said yes then
you said you were part of a board
where you were in a room correct me if
I'm wrong either report to the board you
have to report to the board with the it
was yourself to report to the board
Melinda Gates and Jeff Bezos Jeff Bezos
one Howard one or two others here and
how Joseph one of them he was one so how
was that
when you were dealing with you know
three personalities one is the wife and
now they run the Gates Foundation and
trillion out to trillion dollar company
guys right and a number one coffee
company in the world
mmm how was dad watching all these
personalities their corresponding and
working together it was actually really
very controlled very quiet Dan Levitan
who's the CEO of Maron really controlled
most of it Schultz is the money behind
at all you know the gave the Gates's had
invested in because it was healthcare
early dot-com trying to deliver medicine
you know over the internet and over
phones but Jeff Bezos was very young in
his business back in simply had the
warehouse was only doing books was
actually really reserved it was 2,000 oh
they said it's on these Wow so but he
was on the board and he was already
being seen by I think the other tech
giants at that time as being someone who
was going somewhere and Melinda Gates is
very very kind very thoughtful I don't
think did a lot that I can remember I
mean it's 20 years ago almost but she
was very very thoughtful I mean very
strategic and in and also very I think
very strong as a personality in a
boardroom like that he was very strong
as a personality really you're very
controlled very quiet but very strong
Wow Dan Levitan was the guy very
engaging gal who was the CEO of maverick
was the Ossetians a stronger personality
or Bezos short-shorts I think Beezus is
far brighter academically I mean or
intellectually I think he's just
brilliant I think shows is someone who
just who works very hard who will not
give up under any circumstance
I think Beezus is the same but Beezus
had a far greater vision and his far
more expansive in the way that he looks
at the world we're sure says really he's
got one product and it's developed that
one product into something that has
scaled you know but it's still the same
product
none of what's crazy about where you
lived Seattle I mean you're talking
about diesels gates Schultz I mean
that's and then obviously you have the
rest of the names you got Paul Allen
who's no longer true and then Ballmer
who moved to you know you know LA but
that is a I mean two out of the four
trillion auto companies are under the
same city well you're dead Boeing there
you've got a lot of other ones yes like
REI which are much smaller but there are
a lot of great guy mean amazing how is
that why is that why it's kind of like
pure fluke like you know Armenians
attach funny story yeah every Middle
Eastern Armenian
lives in Glendale California right
Assyrians tore luck the other day I
spoke on this about a thousand people
have 100 Assyrians showed up in Turlock
from tore lock right or you know you
have a Iranians Persians live in Beverly
Hills or Santa Monica right why why
Seattle I don't know you've got serial
killers in Seattle really do Vancouver
CLO with the world's greatest serial
killers hail from so I I don't know
whether it's you stay inside all day
thinking through issues it's too much
rain and the weather I don't know maybe
it's the precipice I don't know I I
really don't know I would be curious if
somebody knew because you know they did
a study on why Silicon Valley and I know
how that became what it is and now
they're trying to do to Austin and
Atlanta's music Nashville is Excel of
these places but I'd be curious in about
Seattle so you know gates I know Bill
Gates I've heard many different things
about Bill Gates right personality-wise
you see Steve Jobs and you say oh my
gosh I mean I've heard Steve Jobs throw
stuff Arana hey watch the movies about
Steve Jobs one was Ashton Kutcher plated
another one was played by another guy
was like almost like a year or two years
that all these movies were coming out
about Steve Jobs I don't know if you
remember that so you're like who
really Steve Jobs but Bill Gates not
everybody knows you just kind of read
about who he was and I hear that his
temper was out of control where he was
almost maniacal about what he wanted to
do so having worked with a lot of these
folks some of them were billionaires and
you work with that were associated with
some of these companies what can you
tell us about Bill Gates's personality
that you know about I thought a lot of
people worked really closely with him I
mean I really have back in that because
I got to Seattle in 91 and yeah you know
Microsoft was big but it wasn't nearly
that big and I've worked a lot of people
the early hundred employees and whatever
else but I think he has something else
called Asperger's which is generally
very you know analytical and very strong
academically in terms of the sciences
and obviously computer science but as
strong as they are in the intellect and
the scientific part of life the logic in
almost diminishes their social capacity
and the emotional capacity they don't
feel so the boundaries and they they
wouldn't worry about saying something
that would hurt somebody else get it
done you know why you want to go home
what are you got to go home for gates
got married somewhat late in life I mean
you know oh you know around in his 40s
because why relationship you know it's
it's not important what's important is
the code get the code out and when I
first got yeah I'd go the campus of
Microsoft and I to the the head of HR
many years ago and she actually said you
know one of the things we value with
people is ADHD Nadd because they think
creatively we want people who can work
and they can almost work in hyper states
for a few days because that's really the
DNA of what Microsoft was in the early
days they wouldn't sleep for two three
days and they would be found under a
desk after a few days get the job done
and think analytically think creatively
think in these hyper states and if you
get the job done you get the project
done that's what matters and that's so
much what Microsoft is it's it's very
project oriented you work in a project
you're an employee of Microsoft when the
project's done you you actually go
through an interview process
to be involved in new projects or maybe
even in the new division you know you
you can achieve very often choose to
move around and you apply to be become
part of a team so get the job done get
that project down get that product you
know finishing out of that so it's
almost like egg I've read a book two
books one is called first rate madness
and another book called hypomanic edge
and it talked about the level of
craziness and success in America like
how many and he Taba bipolar ADHD
hypomanic hypo so mainly a manic then a
spurt Asperger's is it Asperger's
Asperger's surges bu g RS c RK g so all
of these things you read about and you
say you know there's so even autism
there's a certain level of genius in it
right so I've worked with a few people
that had Asperger's purges and it was
very interesting because nothing hurt
it's just very logical no emotion none
of this stuff taking place and in that
kind of an environment do you almost see
like a thread between the guys that make
it to the highest level that they have a
higher level of threshold for pain and
they don't really get respond too much
emotionally I think in the tech industry
very much sir I don't think in a lot of
under industries I think it's like it I
think a lot of great CEOs are very
socially aware and very emotionally
intelligent
I don't think Gates is at all but I
think being married to Melinda Gates who
is very much that way I think is really
helped him I think a lot of other CEOs
may not you know Gates obviously didn't
go to college he was far ahead of going
to college he knew what he knew yeah and
he really couldn't teach you much you
ought to think but I think a lot of
other CEOs really know how to manage
people they read people they understand
people
Bill Gates understood code he understood
you know that the technical world and he
was brilliant at that and he got other
people around like balm and others who
you know was really just interesting
characters one guy dance and rambling
guy he was just yeah did he kind of
balance him out a little bit did him a
pall on a balance not a little bit I
think somewhat Ellen
and exited pretty pretty early I mean he
got sick and I think he got a little
cameo or something and yet base he left
and he really followed what he loved in
life he loved sport well he loved
creativity of course Yossarian a moving
experience music project or yeah the big
monstrosity and the Space Needle he
created he was into music you said in
sports he was into the arts yeah I
remember as a Venice and his yacht was I
don't know if you call that a yacht oh
that's not a yacht sure it's 150 million
dollar yacht slash ship but a helicopter
but you know pad on the top of it it was
a very interesting you know when you
when you read about all these
personalities how much how much in
Seattle is there recruiting like Seattle
you know Microsoft people recruiting
Amazon Amazon people recruiting but is
there a lot of that going on the zone
take from Microsoft Amazon takes they
had great I'm the best of Microsoft
Microsoft's really been reinvented with
Nadella coming in there it's brought in
a lot of new talent but a lot of the old
established talent at Microsoft has gone
to Amazon do they do despite each other
is there like yeah is it like you know
red sox-yankees type of energy or at
this point no one really cares Asia it's
very different companies I mean they're
really out but you know when you are
taking major talent from Microsoft and
you know building you know it sends you
what the data was trying to do with the
cloud and they've done that at Amazon by
taking many of the the top 10 of
Microsoft
I think there's it's good competition
but obviously Amazon is so much bigger
in terms of what they are doing and how
they you know how they view the world
and Microsoft you know the Dell has done
really great things that Microsoft he's
got them back focus very impressive
because there was a lot of people said
Microsoft is done you know if they come
out with these free software's that
Google's and they put them out there and
what is Microsoft gonna do to make money
very very strategic moves they made very
strategic moves image he is using a good
guy how do you how do you view
Amazon to yourself cuz I know we were
talking about how Amazon gets even more
data than Google does how do you view
what Amazon is doing right now because I
know they're dominating the mall
your place they they're absolutely
ruthless I think they're almost like
what Microsoft was back when cases at
least 20s and 30s they were absolutely
ruthless in their quest for really
perfection and be able to the other day
it really is it's got it the closer to
perfection the closer to asking
questions about everything and I think
they've really honed the science of
trying to figure out the right questions
to ask and they're asked constantly and
they are people are pushed to answer
them you don't let things just hang it
at Amazon you are pushed yo to a
conclusion to an answer and you're not
allowed to just let things progress and
somehow business develop you business is
developed and is it a high-pressure type
of an environment is very very very is
it a place where if I work out like am I
going to chase to add it to my resume or
am I going because I'd like to work at
this place for 10 or 20 years I don't
think anyone would zone for that I think
really the gather could be understanding
it for the Amazon you're there for two
years
it really is I've got friends for
recruiters for Amazon and I regularly
have people who come out of you you TD
and Nancy and SMU that I extend to some
of these recruiters they get hired and
everyone wants to work for Amazon
because there's always more work and
they pay them decently but it is very
high pressure you they don't deal with
mistakes very well how do they deal with
them
you don't last there figure out of there
very quickly if you make oh really you
don't repeat the same thing more than
once or twice and you really don't
you're out of there and the demands
really are you have got to do what they
want you to do and they don't apologize
because they see themselves as the you
know they are the best at everything now
they really believe that and to some
extent they proving it out if you want
to look at the externals but I know a
lot of people who've left they're very
burned out who are at Microsoft for
15-20 years who within two years of
Amazon are you know they're maybe in
their mid to late 40s but they done they
are so done with anything
professionally and they don't have to do
anything but they they don't want to do
anything I think that's somewhat
problematic because I think people
always need to know that they have got
more to give in life yeah I agree
and what what's causing it is it there
is there any element of fun and any
element of recognition any element of
man you're doing a great job so proud of
you any element of that or no if we're
seeking perfection the games got to be
at a whole different level I think it's
more the the recognition is you
performed I don't think that and you're
paid very well that's the recognition
that's it I primarily I mean I from what
I know and I really do I've I played
cricket in CLI I you know I was a
cricket I played with a lot of these
guys saw the Microsoft cricket teams so
I got in with a lot of the guys who are
really high up in Microsoft and I
connect with them whenever I go back to
Seattle we always get together and we
you know go out to eat and I'll go watch
and play a game and they're all getting
old and pudgy like me you know I'm older
than most them but they they tell me the
stories I mean they really do and some
of them are heads of major divisions
getting in data the guy who wrote the
book and sequel server Kate and Patel he
was hired into there and like he's done
very well there but they're all tired
they they're pushed and they're excited
but they get tired very quickly
Microsoft is a very different organism
and really is they've created a far more
congenial atmosphere there you walk in
there is foosball tables and there's
pac-man machines and they building a
cricket stadium at Microsoft and they're
right next thing called Mary Moore Park
they're right by a big lake and it's
it's very it's just a lot easier as an
atmosphere as a culture so yeah we talk
about mental disorder earlier what are
your thoughts about how we are solving
mental disorders today because you're
seeing immediate - you know medication
immediately we've gone to all this stuff
and you know you don't understand I need
help with this how do you view that
because I know you've dealt with this
for a while so the way that I look at it
is part of what I've really got into
it's called positive psychology it's a
psychology project positive positive
sorry
got a mouth thing but it positive
psychology puzzle psychology is a
psychology of human happiness so it says
what instead of saying what depresses us
we say what are the patterns of the
things that make us happy what are the
patterns of the things that make us
connected with other people so social
psychology mm-hmm so we study things
like that in education in mental health
even in addiction I gave a talk to a
bunch of psychiatrists and psychologists
recently on addiction and talked about
this concept of flow how when I've
enabled people to discover talents and
really engage in a meaningful way so
many of the addiction issues that they
came to me with or some of the people
that I worked with they go away they
become addicted to what is delivered
back to them in life I think so much the
psychology when it looks at simply
what's wrong how do we fix it it's
problematic as well because so much of
life is about perspective and I if I see
myself as being weak as being less than
I'm highly susceptible to being
depressed being anxious to being
isolated from other people when I see
myself as being important as someone who
has something to give I have a place to
give it I have a place to you know
create wealth and to give it to other
people and to see their lives change my
mental health as a far greater
likelihood of thriving than me simply
having to go back and undo some sort of
trauma that I really will never get a
grasp on you can go back and you can try
and figure out whatever bad thing
happened to you in life and good luck if
you ever really get understand that
you're not so you're not from the
typical traditional clinical you know a
psychologist or therapist sister says
hey what affected when you were a kid
this is why you are the way or - we've
all got what we've got and we've all
most of us got in someone good measure
life has not been kind to most people
everybody has got something in their
background they've got a loss and
they've got disappointment they've got
hurt and they've got pain and they've
been used and they whatever what makes
me bigger than all of that and if I
don't know what makes me bigger than
that all those things will make me less
then how do I find out what's bigger
than all that you do some hard work go
into the work of discovery you find out
what have I got to give intellectually
what what what am i exception I'd you
know intellectually what have other
people said about me this forensics
where a mine flow intellectually what
are my friends and family whatever
experts said about me where am I happy
when I walk into a classroom what
classes do I look forward to going to in
social groups I said my oldest son he's
got his three or four close friends he's
not happy and in big groups Mike Mike
second son what where do you impact
people small groups law groups you to
you take some YouTube you know it's your
physical presence it's your intellect
it's your ability to connect with people
it's your ability to have people in
social media put out a product that is
not just thrown out there people wanted
they grab them they get a hold of it so
it's finding you know how do I handle
crisis how do I it's talking about my
big why I mean everyone talks about the
big why now I ask the kid the other day
is about to go to college said why are
you going to college she had no answer
for it at all
majority of kids who go to college now
if they haven't sat down and they
haven't figured out why are they going
they've got something that they want to
develop and become bigger and better out
they've got a career in a future ahead
of them but it all comes down to for me
it's design determines purpose know what
you're uniquely capable of doing and I
have a simple model it's called spice SP
is who are you spiritually that is in
terms of character in terms of motive
and mission in life why do you do the
things that you do that's SP physical
what have I got to give who am I
physically it can be physical touch we
went out to lunch and you put yo you
reach the cross and you touch my arm you
connect with people like that it's not
just being a physical athlete it can be
somebody who when you stand up and speak
you command presence in a courtroom you
command it can be something quiet my
sister's psychologists people coming to
office she creates a calm presence
because of who
is that's physical presence who you then
yeah that's the P intellectually who are
you emotionally who you how do you
handle crisis how do you how emotionally
intelligent are you how do you read
people how do you feel you know how do
you manage those feelings how do you
manage disappointment how have you
overcome bad things in your life and
then it's a socially who you socially so
it spies spies as you know is motional
okay SP IES I look at myself I love
connecting with people you know I have
lived at Starbucks in many ways for the
last three since I got to Seattle I'll
go there Starbucks anywhere in this
country or anywhere anywhere I'll have
10 friends within a few days I will know
everybody I can there's certain
Starbucks that I'll go into people think
that I some are owned them because
everybody is like shares when I walk in
there people know me and I want to
connect with people I love you know I
actually I got a little african-american
church here in Dallas I'll preach this
sometimes I love it I love speaking it's
just it's Who I am
it's people in general the worst part of
where I connect socially is if I'm at a
sane networking event or just a small
event when someone says well want you to
stand up and tell who who you are what
you do it's like I'm a delivering idiot
I it's like for what I know I am I know
what I do what you know I honestly will
get anxious but I spoke in front of
5,000 people it doesn't faze me at all I
I don't I'll stand up and sit down I've
said what I said and it hasn't touched
me you know I was in flow up be up for
an hour and I'll sit down fell by 2
minutes but find out where you thrive
fine opportunity to do more of that find
out when you what's of audiences you
speak to that it most deeply impacted
you know what what's the result of
change so this is very interesting and
we're very aligned on this I you say
forensics I say study or trance show
study or trans ask yourself what kind of
people you get along with who you don't
why don't you what causes what happened
there's a repetition that yeah
no doubt about it it's repetition with
gathering data about yourself which are
somewhat forensics
you got to do on your own cell so I like
that spy spiritually how can you give
back spiritually how can you give back
physically intellectual what do you have
to offer emotionally and socially it's
right spice spine brilliant easy to
remember it is mark this is what I think
you truly it's been a blast
what can people find your book is that
on Amazon yeah I'm actually rewriting it
at the moment but it's on Amazon and I'm
actually putting a spy's whole analogy
into it and shorting it it's too long
it's a very good book short or something
we're gonna put the link below thank you
Amazon you can go order the book and can
people find your social media are you on
social media for them they find you they
can I'm what the links below is what are
you the best way for their own personal
discoveries in my life seem calm okay
it's very similar to what Jordan
Peterson does my life seen Cena yes see
any like a crime scene investigation
it's my life scene and so it's a whole
pro 64 different videos and tests and
integration into your life to take you
through the whole spies analogy and you
profile your life just like an FBI
profile it would profile a criminal you
profiling which writer great and
exceptional about your life I love that
we're gonna put the link with a blank
ear that is a little appreciation for
coming thank you so much thank you need
to meet you in big be a thank you